je vous parle d'un produit qui est
absolument dingue pour la maison si vous
voulez solutionner tous vos problèmes de
Wi-Fi vous allez voir alors c'est dans
une très grosse boîte c'est une très
grosse bête on est là on est chez orbi
c'est un truc de fou c'est Netgear qui
fait ça je sais pas si on dit jamais
Netgear on est gear peut-être qu'en
anglais on dit Netgear en tout cas moi
je dis souvent en ire alors si vous
connaissez pas net gear n'est dire c'est
une société américaine qui est basée à
San josé en Californie au cœur de la
Silicon Valley et qui sont en
spécialiste de toutes les technologies
réseau filaire Wi-Fi mobilité
particulier bref ici il couvre tous les
besoins et c'est surtout un spécialiste
de la maison connectée depuis pas moins
de 25 ans autant vous dire qu'ici ils
ont l'expertise alors le produit c'est
celui-là regardez c'est écrit juste là
on est sur le orbi Black Edition c'est
une énorme boîte qui passe très très
lourd et surtout qu'il a vraiment vous
rendre service regardez vous le marque
ici quoi de bande Wi-Fi 6 mèche système
on a un truc de fou alors je vais tout
vous expliquer tout vous détailler mais
avant toute chose je voulais d'abord
l'ouvrir avec vous pour vous montrer ce
qu'il y avait à l'intérieur et là on est
sur un truc juste fou fou donc si vous
cherchez une vous allez voir ici il y a
vraiment de quoi faire comment ça
s'ouvre ce truc déjà alors on commence
par retirer cette espèce de chaussettes
étui ensuite on a une petite languette
là on tire comme un sparadra et c'est
ouvert hop on a ensuite toutes les
informations pour l'installation ici
alors télécharger l'application c'est
curieux du vice avec netgearmor on va
tout regarder d'où mort with you app ok
alors là en français bravo Monsieur gros
félicitations donc ben on fait la même
vous téléchargez l'application vous
sécurisez et vous faites tout sur votre
application on vous explique comment ça
marche donc voilà alors en fait vous
allez retrouver ici à l'intérieur 3 hop
en fait la question c'est vous avez une
maison vous avez une grande maison et
vous voulez avoir du répartiteur vous
voulez répartir uniformément le wifi
dans votre maison si vous avez
différents étages et 6 fois ou si vous
avez juste une box en wifi si c'est que
vous voulez aller plus loin alors c'est
pas la peine de venir prendre une box en
wifi ce vous gardez votre box par contre
vous passez tout directement vous
confier toutes les systèmes de wifi à
vos orbies et ce qui est génial ici
c'est que vos orbites et bien ils vont
sentir le wifi de façon uniforme dans
votre maison donc ça c'est super cool et
en plus de ça ils vont le faire en wifi
6e autant vous dire que là on va avoir
des débits de Dingo ça va être juste
génial donc le programme aujourd'hui
c'est de venir ouvrir tout ça c'est de
regarder comment ça marche c'est de
comprendre le fonctionnement de
comprendre la configuration avec ces
jolis petits routeurs qui en plus sur
les éléments de décoration sont très
chouettes 3 mois j'aime beaucoup donc on
va regarder ça on va regarder
l'installation on va regarder la
configuration on va regarder comment ça
marche et vous vous allez me dire ce que
vous en pensez en bas dans les
commentaires c'est toujours une vidéo
qui est réalisée en partenariat avec
Netgear qui m'a demandé de venir vous
présenter sa solution orbi vous êtes
prêt on va y aller
je vous montre l'installation c'est
assez facile je prends mon ordi je viens
le brancher ici sur le secteur je viens
me brancher ensuite sur le 10 giga que
je viens brancher sur le 10 giga de la
prise Ethernet de ma box voilà c'est
bien 10 giga même si vous le voyez pas
forcément bien je viens me brancher ici
comme ça je suis en full 10 giga et ça
devrait le faire je me mets mon premier
satellite juste ici au niveau de mon
bureau pour l'installation de satellite
c'est très facile vous avez qu'à prendre
votre bloc de d'Aline qui fournit avec
vous venez vous le branchez là et c'est
tout vous avez absolument rien d'autre à
faire une fois que vous l'avez configuré
c'est extrêmement simple vous avez tout
dans votre application vous gérez tout
directement je vous montre comment
utiliser l'application et ce que vous
pouvez faire avec vous allez voir il y a
énormément de choses à faire c'est très
simple très facile à utiliser c'est une
solution pour la famille pour tout le
monde alors attention la solution coûte
quand même relativement cher on se parle
bien ici d'une solution à
1899 euros 99 et d'ailleurs il y a un
code promo qui vous donne 10% de remise
sur toute la boutique le code c'est
Monsieur gros 10 et ça vous donne accès
à une réduction maximale de 100 euros de
remise ça vous permet de faire quelques
économies sur l'achat de votre pack et
une fois de plus le lien est en bas dans
la description on se parle vraiment
d'une solution voilà en wifi 6e
extrêmement compétent il y a plein de
différentes solutions qu'on peut venir
retrouver chez Netgear prochaine il y a
beaucoup de solutions vous l'avez vu
avec cette série 960 mais vous en
trouverez également d'autres qui peuvent
être vachement intéressantes comme
notamment la série 860 une fois de plus
je vous mets le lien dans la description
allez jeter un coup d’œil directement
sur le site de Netgear c'est très cool
très transverse on peut rajouter des
satellites mais avant toute chose je
vais vous expliquer comment ça se passe
qu'on comprenne un peu la technologie en
fait si vous avez une maison ça
ressemble à peu près à une maison vous
allez voir c'est une maison avec un toit
c'est mieux d'avoir un toit sur une
maison parce que quand il pleut sinon
c'est rapidement le bazar et vous avez
des étages on va se dire que votre porte
d'entrée elle se situe juste là et que
vous avez plusieurs pièces dans votre
maison voilà et vous avez même de
l'espace dans les combles donc votre
porte d'entrée est là et on va se dire
que votre box elle est pas ici donc vous
avez la box qui situe là votre box elle
va venir rayonner dans un coin qui est à
peu près celui-là vous voyez elle va
venir rayonner un peu comme ça et puis
plus vous montez et moins bah il se
passe pas grand chose parce qu'en fait
votre réseau Wi-Fi il aime pas trop
passer au niveau du plafond donc vous
êtes ici vous êtes bien couvert et plus
vous vous éloignez et moins vous êtes
ouvert et bon au bout du bout du bout
par exemple là et là il y a strictement
plus rien donc il faut pouvoir récupérer
du signal donc ce qu'il faut que vous
fassiez c'est que là vous avez votre Box
vous venez poser votre routeur que vous
venez de collecter directement mais je
vais vous expliquer comment ça se passe
comment on fait ensuite vous venez poser
un satellite j'en sais rien moi par
exemple ici à l'étage hop premier
satellite je viens de poser directement
à l'étage ce qui fait que le satellite
lui il vient récupérer les informations
de votre routeur et lui à son tour il
vient émettre alors il vient émettre
comme ça comme ça comme ça hop un peu
ici il vient émettre il vient et mettre
il vient et mettre et ensuite on veut
venir encore amplifier le reste et bien
on peut venir se mettre à notre
satellite j'en sais rien moi par exemple
par ici je vous le fais grosso modo lui
il va venir envoyer du signal hop par
ici il va venir aussi envoyer un petit
peu aussi par en bas bref on vient
couvrir toute la maison et on vient
récupérer on va courir toute la maison
je suis pas un grand dessinateur mais
baisser ça c'est qu'en fait vous
récupérez votre signal ici et vous
l'envoyer directement et vous couvrez
l'ensemble de votre maison et ce qui est
très cool c'est qu'avec cette solution
là vous venez couvrir rien qu'avec votre
routeur et vos deux satellites vous
couvrez 800 mètres carrés et moi il faut
que j'achète des marqueurs qui marchent
mieux donc là vous avez vraiment de quoi
faire et si vous avez une maison encore
plus grande et bien il existe un pack
vous allez pouvoir avoir un satellite de
plus si vous en prenez avec des packs de
4 donc avec le routeur et trois
satellites vous montez à 1060 mètres
carrés et plus vous en rajoutez plus
vous en aurez donc le truc est quand
même vachement bien très facile très
sexy et très cool pour la maison donc ça
c'est un très bon point après je vous
explique comment ça se passe moi ce que
je vous conseillerais réellement à venir
faire comme config c'est-à-dire c'est ce
que j'ai fait chez moi vous avez votre
box votre box elle est là ça c'est la
box de votre fournisseur d'accès
Internet Vous la gardez bien évidemment
directement sur votre box et je voulais
montrer sur la prise 10 Go vous venez
connecter directement ici votre orby
votre orbi numéro 1 c'est votre routeur
il est ici lui il est connecté et après
vous avez votre satellite qui vont venir
communiquer sans fil donc là il y a pas
de fil c'est du sans fil avec le
satellite 1 et avec le satellite 2 voilà
comment ça se passe ok ça c'est très
facile ce qu'il faut venir faire sur
votre box ici vous venez déjà couper le
wifi ça sert à rien d'avoir deux réseaux
Wi-Fi qui se baladent dans la maison
celui-là et celui-là après si vous êtes
vraiment novice qu'il faut que vous
sachiez c'est que votre réseau qui est
émis par lui sera le même que celui-là
ce qu'on appelle le SSD le SSID en fait
c'est le nom
Upla il majuscule plutôt c'est le nom de
votre réseau chez vous si par exemple
vous appelez mon bon réseau chez moi et
bien vous aurez mon bon réseau ici mon
bon réseau ici et quand vous vous
déplacerez chez vous et bien en fonction
de l'endroit vous allez être et votre
votre appareil notamment votre
smartphone ou les appareils que vous
avez chez vous vont se connecter là où
le signal sera le meilleur après il faut
savoir et c'est très cool avec cette
technologie que nous propose ici Netgear
avec les herbies c'est que vous avez en
fait trois bandes de fréquence vous
allez avoir d'abord 2,5 pense vraiment
Aurélien à t'acheter des crayons qui
marchent le 2,5 voilà le 2,4 voilà 2,4
soyons précis c'est pas 2,5 c'est 2,4
giga Hertz sont des giga Hertz bravo
Monsieur greu vous avez ensuite le 5
giga Hertz ça c'est ce que vous
retrouvez avec tout ce qui va être
classique il va pas être en wifi et puis
vous avez ensuite le 6 GHz voilà on se
parle bien ici gigahertz à chaque fois
le 2 GHz
et tout il
émet un truc qu'on va utiliser un
peu des bandes de fréquence et plus les
ondes vont être courtes mais plus vous
aurez de débit donc quand vous arrivez
sur le 5 GHz vous allez avoir une portée
qui va être un peu moins vous allez
envoyer un peu moins de signal à
distance par contre le signal va être
beaucoup plus puissant et lorsque vous
arrivez sur du 6 GHz vous allez mettre
fatalement moins loin par contre les
débits vont être beaucoup plus haut donc
quand on est en wifi 6e fatalement il
faut venir mettre des petits satellites
comme ça sans quoi ça passerait pas
autant vous allez pouvoir venir capter
le 2,4 gigahertz de votre hauteur un peu
plus loin autant le 6G Hertz vous
l'aurez pas si vous avez pas les
satellites il y a une particularité à
connaître qui est super intéressante ici
chez orbis et d'ailleurs leur
spécificité c'est à dire que eux ils
vont ouvrir un canal de communication en
plus qui est basé ici sur le 5 GHz en
gros le 5 GHz ça va être coupé en deux
vous avez la première partie qui est
dédiée au bac rôle donc au fait venir
faire communiquer votre routeur avec vos
satellites et la deuxième partie elle
est dédiée à tous vos périphériques qui
vont pouvoir venir se connecter sur la
bande de fréquence 5 gigahertz cette
technologie qui permet aux satellite et
aux routeur de communiquer en dehors des
trois bandes c'est une technologie
brevetée qui s'appelle bac fall on vient
donc ici ça franchir des murs et toute
la structure de votre domicile donc on
pourra venir communiquer très facilement
les uns avec les autres et ce qui est
bien c'est que ici alors ça va dépendre
une fois de plus de votre bande passante
parce que si vous avez par exemple ici
la fibre et que vous avez pas énormément
de débit et bien lui il va pas pouvoir
inventer ce qu'il a pas voyez donc lui
il va reprendre le signal la formation
qui va de là donc ce qui est cool par
contre c'est que si vous avez de la
fibre et que ça tartine à Max ce qui est
cool c'est que là vous pouvez venir vous
brancher directement et à monter jusqu'à
10 Gigabits par seconde alors je pense
pas globalement que votre opérateur vous
permet d'avoir du digigabit par seconde
mais il existe certains opérateurs qui
on va quand même la Grosse Patate donc
vous pouvez aller au max jusqu'à 10
Gigabits par seconde et c'est quand même
pas dégueu et je vais vous faire un
Speed Test dans quelques instants parce
que j'ai un iphone qui lui est en wifi 6
et j'ai un samsung galaxy S22 ultra qui
est en wifi 6e et vous allez voir que le
wifi 6e il y a quand même une très
grosse différence parce que le wifi 6
versus le wifi 6e on va se dire que le E
c'est pas grand chose c'est extendide
mais on va quasiment multiplier par deux
vous allez voir je vous montre dans
quelques instants alors chaque base base
routeur ou satellite Orbit 960 possède
11 Gigabits par le monde de wifi avec 16
antennes ça permet donc de ne jamais
vous dire ralentir le réseau et d'avoir
une collection optimale on est sur le
premier système WIFI mèche 6e quad bande
du marché s'envoient la Grosse Patate
quoi de bonde pourquoi une bande de
bande 3 bandes plus la 4e bande pour
venir faire connecter les appareils
entre eux et en plus de ça vous pouvez
venir lier directement à ses appareils
jusqu'à 200 appareils 200 appareils chez
vous alors après vous me direz ça va
quand même relativement vite une ampoule
connectée un appareil deux ans plus
connecté deux appareils ça va très très
vite chez vous un smartphone un
ordinateur une Google next et compagnie
ça va très vite mais vous pouvez aller
jusqu'à 200 appareils avec cette
solution là que je vous présente
aujourd'hui et ce qui est très cool ce
pouvait diffuser des flux des flux vidéo
jusqu'en 4K mais on peut monter
également jusqu'en 8k même si c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui la 8k il y a globalement
très peu de personnes qui l'utilisent
sinon vous pouvez très bien venir
brancher deux trois TV en 4K ça
fonctionnera très bien donc vous avez
ici le débit nécessaire donc en termes
de débit ça va le faire tout se passe
dans l'application orbi Netgear donc là
vous voyez votre connexion donc là hop
connexion locale je me mets là dessus
vous voyez donc que vous êtes en ligne
voyez votre appareil vous avez deux
satellites et après vous pas mal de
choses à venir voir alors je vous
explique c'est très simple en haut à
droite une petite cloche avec des
notifications tout ce qui s'est connecté
tout ce qui s'est passé tous vos
rapports et compagnie alors gestion des
périphériques regardez on met que j'ai
20 périphériques alors déjà j'ai un truc
qui est séparé j'ai home avec un H ça
sont tous mes appareils à la maison mais
je suis venu séparer j'ai créé un profil
et vous le voyez en bas ajouter un
profil en fait j'ai créé un profil pour
mon fils et je lui ai mis ses appareils
donc lui il a une Nintendo switch ce qui
me permet ensuite de venir paramétrer
pas mal de choses ça me permet de mettre
des règles par rapport à lui niveau de
contenu c'est un contenu enfant je peux
venir mettre des règles heart couché je
peux dire qu'il vient se coucher à tout
à l'heure donc dès lors qu'il se couche
hop son appareil il est coupé il a plus
accès au wifi il faut mettre des limites
de temps ici et ça donc c'est un truc
qui est quand même vachement bien donc
il a pas utilisé aujourd'hui
l'historique tout ça parce que il est
puni et ben oui forcément il a fait des
bêtises donc ça il a pas accès et après
on a tous les appareils alors voyez il y
a un truc qui est très très cool c'est
qu'en fait vous vous créez un réseau à
la maison par exemple vous l'appellera
vous l'appellerez mon réseau ça c'est
votre SSID c'est le nom du réseau sur
lequel vous allez vous connecter vous
l'appelez mon réseau lui il vous permet
de faire différents trucs et ça c'est
vachement bien et ça permet déjà donc ça
c'est votre réseau sur lequel vous allez
vous connecter avec vos appareils vous
pouvez créer un réseau qui sera là pour
vos invités donc vous l'appellerez mon
réseau tirer guest comme ça vos
amis qui viendront chez vous ils
n'auront pas accès à vos appareils
connectés ils ne pourront pas venir
piloter vos appareils connectés il les
verront pas donc ça devient un peu
sécurisé le truc et ils auront un mot de
passe dédié à ça et il vient en plus
générer un autre réseau qui est
intéressant donc c'est toujours mon
réseau sauf que là c'est mon réseau qui
va être lié pour tous vos appareils
connectés ce qu'on appelle de l'ioti
hayoti IOT ça veut dire internet of
things l'Internet des Objets donc vous
allez connecter ça va être une sonnette
connectée ça va être des ampoules
connectées ça va être des enfants
collectés tous ces petits appareils chez
vous ils vont venir se mettre là donc
ils sont sur un réseau à part et tout
est quand même plutôt pas mal sauf que
et souvent on se dit ah il y a un truc
qui peut être problématique si vous avez
par exemple de SSID chez vous par
exemple vous avez votre ordinateur votre
PC ou votre Mac qui est connecté ici et
si vous mettez votre imprimante ici vous
vous dites en fait je peux pas venir
imprimer parce que je ne suis pas sur le
même réseau connecté en wifi sauf que si
il le connaît il sait que c'est un
réseau pour les objets connectés donc si
vous lancez une impression en wi-fi
depuis votre PC sur votre réseau là il
va le switcher directement ici et il va
l'envoyer il va imprimer directement ici
donc ces deux réseaux ils viennent
vraiment échanger vous avez une vraie
communication qui se fait ici par contre
ici vous n'avez pas de communication ça
vient vraiment sécurisé votre maison et
ça c'est très très chouette donc là vous
voyez je vois bien que j'ai mon
imprimante vous voyez là il m'a mis que
je suis connecté au 2,4 gigahertz quand
je vous ai pas et tout à l'heure qui va
quand même relativement loin mais qui a
moins de débit pour venir imprimer j'ai
pas besoin d'un gros débit à yoti wifi
donc là je l'ai bien ici mon aspirateur
j'ai mes caméras Arlo j'ai mon samsung
galaxy S22 ultra et là je suis connecté
en 6 Go Hertz vous voyez et comme j'ai
dit wifi 6e c'est très cool et je vais
retrouver mon Iphone j'ai mon iPhone qui
est là et là je suis en 5 GHz pourquoi
parce que sur l'iPhone 14 pro max je
n'ai pas de wifi 6e et tous les
appareils où je n'ai pas de wifi 6e je
ne vais pas sur la bande 6 GHz par
exemple je vais vous prendre un iPad de
5e génération la connecter en 2,4 giga
Hertz un iPad de 6e génération même la
connecter en 6 GHz voilà comme ça vous
voyez un peu tout mon macbook pro il est
en 5 GHz donc comme ça en fonction de là
vous allez avoir du wifi 6 ça se passe
comme ça donc j'ai ma télé j'ai mes
ampoules connectées donc je retrouve
tout ici je peux tout piloter ça c'est
vachement cool je vois également les
appareils qui sont hors ligne et qui
sont pas en ligne et voyez une fois de
plus là par exemple là j'ai mon petit
bridge Philippe chou et marqué maison en
bas il met un petit port c'est que je
suis connecté directement en éternel
dessus et comme ça je vois exactement se
connecter en wifi et pas en wifi ensuite
il y a alors toute une question de de
sécurité c'est un abonnement vous pouvez
venir prendre qui vous est offert au
début c'est quand même pas mal de faire
pendant un mois qui vous donnera une
notation qui vous dira si vous êtes bien
sécurisé oui non qu'est-ce qui peut être
modifié les choses à faire si et ça ok
il vous donne des conseils il peut venir
vous proposer d'installer votre
antivirus [ __ ] Defender security ici
univers scanner vos appareils donc dès
qu'il y a un nouvel appareil qui arrive
il le scanne et voici une vulnérabilité
ou pas et vous maîtrisez tout
directement alors il faut venir
autoriser directement ici les
notifications comme ça vous les recevez
directement donc ça c'est un truc qui
vient prendre en plus mais ça vaut le
coup de venir l'essayer voyez moi il me
reste 29 jours je
aussi partager le réseau sans fait si je
le souhaite et je fais la même chose
avec mon réseau wifi invité donc quand
j'ai les invités je leur pousse ça
directement et il se connecte au réseau
invité c'est très très cool et ensuite
j'ai la mesure du trafic je vois
exactement ce que j'ai eu en trafic une
moyenne et si ça comme ça j'ai de la
vraie analyse donc ça c'est un peu
toutes les informations de base qui sont
là qui sont très pratiques après je peux
aller un peu plus loin donc je vais
retrouver mes paramètres les paramètres
du routeur donc là j'ai les informations
où je peux venir chercher à des mises à
jour les paramètres Wi-Fi c'est mon SSD
je veux déjà montré les paramètres
d'ioti wifi pour qu'on peut venir
l'activer ou désactiver je vous
conseille de venir l'activer une fois de
plus pour avoir un réseau spécial pour
vos objets connectés les paramètres du
wifi invité je voulais montrer le
contrôle parental toute la question de
la sécurité vous venez activer Netgear
Armor c'est l'abonnement pouvez bien
prendre ici et justement ce qui est
super bien c'est que cette solution de
sécurité n'est durement vous est offert
pendant un an si vous achetez le pack et
ça quand même c'est vachement bien et ça
vous laisse le temps de voir venir cette
solution est bien sécurisée tous vos
appareils autant vous dire qu'ici c'est
vachement rassurant accès en tout lieu
alors accès entre deux vous pouvez le
faire parce que moi je l'ai fait ça veut
dire que lorsque je suis loin de chez
moi et bien je peux quand même venir
voir ce qui se passe en terme de
connexion si quelqu'un vient se
connecter alors je suis pas chez moi
j'aurais la notification et je peux
venir couper internet couper sa
collection le dégager bref très pratique
et collecte des données c'est si vous
autorisez net de dire à récupérer des
données pour améliorer leur service moi
je ne l'ai pas fait la gestion de votre
compte personnel Netgear vos abonnements
directement chez Nelly à vous et
retrouver ici contrôle parental et
sécurité le support s'il y a des besoins
à propos on peut se déconnecter on peut
venir rajouter des satellites ça qui est
cool c'est qu'en fait si demain vous
avez besoin d'un satellite de plus vous
rendez compte qu'un satellite vous
manque vous pouvez venir le connecter le
rajouter très très facilement donc vous
voyez l'application elle est assez
simple elle est très claire permet de
gérer votre routeur vos satellites très
facilement vous les pilotez à distance
je vous lance un speedtest directement
de l'iPhone allez j'appuie tac tac tac
ça part hop comme ça on peut le suivre
directement et vous voyez jusqu'où on va
au niveau de l'iPhone alors attendez tac
ça continue ça prend un peu de temps
mais c'est en train de se faire comme ça
vous voyez directement le résultat du
Speed Test bon c'est pas mal hein on
peut avoir un peu de oui mais c'est pas
le truc le plus fou du monde on va
maintenant se le faire directement avec
celui-là le Galaxy S22
ultra Go et là ça part pour le speedtest
et voyez qu'on monte quand même
vachement plus haut c'est pas la même
chose alors après ça va vraiment
dépendre parce que si vous prenez les
deux smartphones et que vous mettez
directement à côté de votre routeur ou à
côté de votre satellite vous allez plein
balle un peu partout mais dès que vous
vous éloignez dans la maison et que vous
n'êtes pas directement collé à savoir
que vous allez venir vous retrouver à
différents endroits de chez vous et bien
ça va pas être la même chose il va y
avoir un écart qui va se creuser plutôt
en faveur du smartphone avec le wifi 6e
donc le wifi si vous le voyez enfin
quand même vachement plus vite et c'est
pour ça que c'est super intéressant de
venir s'équiper en wifi directement avec
une solution complète pour votre maison
jusqu'à 800 mètres carrés 200 appareils
en wifi 6 je trouve ça vachement bien ce
système orbi existe dans deux couleurs
soit en noir soit en blanc moi je trouve
très beau en noir et les gants ça dépend
de la déco de chacun parce que je suis
team noir d'ailleurs dites-moi si vous
êtes plutôt team blanc ou team noir dans
les commentaires l'application que vous
ai montré je voulais montrer sur iOS
mais existe également sur Android et
puis il faut savoir que chaque satellite
routeur va faire un kilo 4 et une fois
de plus n'oubliez pas le code monsieur
Greux 10 qui vous permet d'avoir 10% de
remise sur votre prochain article et
votre mise et plafonnée un maximum de
100 euros et cette remise elle peut être
appliquée à tous les produits de guerre
donc ça c'est un vrai plan donc allez-y
et une fois de plus je vous mets le lien
en bas dans la description voilà pour
les infos dites-moi vous ce que vous en
pensez en bas dans les commentaires on
trouve que c'est une solution
intéressante elle est un peu cher je
vous le cache pas franchement 1899 €, 99
c'est un certain budget mais si vous
voulez ce qu'il y a de mieux aujourd'hui
pour la maison une solution très simple
très clair et bien vous pouvez y aller
et une fois de plus je vous invite
vraiment à me dire jeter un coup d'oeil
directement sur le site de nez de gear
vous avez effectivement les Orbit 960
mais vous avez également ça c'est très
chouette la série 860 et plein d'autres
le lien est en bas dans la description
vous de me dire ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que vous avez déjà essayé un
système de Netgear orbi est-ce que vous
l'avez déjà eu est-ce que vous pourriez
switcher sur celui-là dites moi tout ça
et puis bien évidemment je trouve très
bientôt pour continuer à parler de texte
et ça c'est cool et merci à Netgear
d'avoir sponsorisé cette vidéo je vous
embrasse
une fois de vous et à bientôt Ciao
[Applaudissements]